chair it's come up
on my screen that it's live on youtube
thank you i just wait for lauren to just
say okay
we're live now chairman thank you very
much
uh welcome to russia district council's
remote standards
committee meeting and welcome to anybody
watching this via
the live stream so if we can turn to the
agenda please this evening
agenda item number one apologies for
absence
i understand apologies for absence have
been received from councillor mike's
steptoe
there's anyone else please
no everybody else is present chairman
thank you
uh agenda item number two substitute
members
uh councillor david merrick will be
substituting
for councillor mike steptoe
agenda item number three are there any
non-members attending
um lauren is there anyone they're
on and jen thank you
dendrites number four minutes of the
meeting
held on the 17th of september 2020
are the minutes agreed members if
anybody has
any disagreement with the minutes could
they please raise their
hand icon
if not we will take that as read
i'm just checking no one has indicated
so those minutes are agreed
thank you members gender item number
five
to receive declarations of interest
did a member indicate they're not speak
no sorry that smart dog
smashing through the door thank you
okay um agenda item number five to
receive decorations of interest
members are there any declarations of
interest please
if so please indicate using your hand
icon
no declarations thank you
agenda item number six is the local
investigations and determinations report
october 2020 to march 2021
angela laura our monitoring officer will
present this report
over to you angela
so apologies chairman you think i know
how to meet by now wouldn't you
um thank you chairman yes this is the
second report
um to the committee uh detailing
all complaints and queries that have
been received by myself the monitoring
officer
appended to the reports you will see a
table
listing out uh currently uh
five five sorry six com
is it six six complaints yes six
complaints three of which are still to
be determined
i'm happy to take any questions on this
chairman uh the decision is
for the report to be noted this evening
thank you
thank you angela um members have you got
any questions
please raise your hand if you have
any questions for our officer
chairman councillor gooding is
indicating
thank you councillor mrs gooding would
you like to ask your question please
thank you chairman i just wondered if i
could get some clarification
on um
how are you able to advise me
how it's determined if a counselor is
acting in the capacity as a counsellor
or a member of public
um counsellor mrs good and are you
referring to an item
on the report item number
one item set uh on item uh six
point one and number three
thank you um angela you are able to
answer that please
um without going to the detail of the
complaint i need
uh the arrangements for dealing with
complaints are in our constitution and
um as the law stands in this case or
supports that
um you know uh councils that do have a
right to a private life
and um with regard to determining
whether it's in the capacity is the case
of
taking into consideration the context
the situation
and the facts of the case uh is a
judgment call um
there's no black and what there's no
black and white rule it just depends on
each merit of the case
thank you does that answer your question
counselor mrs gooding
marginally yes
is there any um other question that you
had then
oh thank you i'll leave it there thank
you
um councillor mr hoy i think your your
question was next please yeah thank you
chairman
um apologies i think this problem the
first time i've been on this committee
surprisingly
so i might be asking questions which
everyone else knows the answer to
so that is the case um
items four five and six are to be
determined
does that mean just that it's been
to be determined whether there's a case
to answer or that
they've been pushed further along the
process and they're still being
considered
that's the thing yes yes thank you
councillor yeah now
for clarification the the three cases at
the moment are still in an initial
summary stages
um as to whether there is action to
follow um
it's not actually gone any further than
that yet okay thank you and the second
question
might be along the same lines as
councilman mrs gooding
but i noticed on item three um
we have no further action on the basis
that the subject of the com
of complaint was not acted in the
capacity of
counsellor at the time i don't
particularly have a problem with that i
can understand that's the
decision made was that made
by you as the monitor officer before it
went any further or did it
was there an involvement of an
independent person to decide that or was
it
moved on further into the process no
that was a decision by me
it was um it didn't need to go any
further because it wasn't acting in the
capacity as a counsellor
and sorry just the the final question
then i forget
not what i've been rude it probably
sounds rude um
because i'm new to this complaint
complaints process and i think i should
understand it properly which is why i'm
asking these questions
um on the
i i assume therefore that you are fully
satisfied that you
to my mind that if you're deciding that
that's something which i thought would
have been decided further along the
process
um is it are there some circumstances
where you might fight
was it in your opinion so clear cut that
they weren't acting in that capacity
that you could decide
if it if normally it might be more of
more of a 50 50 balance shall we say
on the balance of probabilities that you
weren't quite sure would that be passed
further along the
complaints process or would this always
be decided by you before pushing it any
further
yeah so base uh generally council hoy
and based on in this particular case
there was a clear-cut information given
to me
um that the um based on the facts that
i've seen
um and evidence that i've seen that this
gentleman
um counselor wasn't acting in
in in the capacity of in his official
capacity as a parish councillor
um if it was 50 50 not so clear cut
you're right i would be
i mean uh generally these complaints
would be passed to an independent person
and
and have their view but in this case
there was um
in my opinion a clear-cut case there
does that answer your questions
myself during the answer yeah that thank
you that makes it
a little bit clearer for me a bit more
understandable thank you thank you
uh councillor mr chris stanley
thank you chairman um just uh one sort
of
observation was uh how how long
does the uh process uh
take from um initial
uh correspondence to to your
uh decision at the end uh angela um
it just seems that people are being
it's to me it looks like people are
being held
in sort of a balance if you like you
know on
on nervous grounds if you like if any
action is going to be taken i just
wondered if
what what the what the length of time is
if if that's a possible question to ask
we do aim to respond within um
the month however uh it depends on the
facts of the case it depends on
resources at the time
i couldn't give you an actual exact
timeline because some some
um depending on the evidence given and
depend on the facts of the case
it can be black and white sometimes it's
not so black and white and it takes uh
time for judgment and and running past
the independent person for their views
so we do aim to get it done within
that's the initial stages that's the
initial summary stage as council hall is
referring to and then
if it was to go to further investigation
it it really depends on um
what the investigator will be looking at
how many witnesses are coming forward
for interview and and so forth so we
again we couldn't give you time on that
depending on how complex the case is as
well
thank you um counselor mr sandy to
answer your question
counselor stanley yes yes thank you
thank you chairman
thank you um councillor
uh miss marriott please
are you okay can you unmute
right hello can you hear me now we can
all it is is i notice there's a common
thread with some of these complaints
that it's about conduct on
social media we had a very good course
recently
on on ways of communicating on social
media is it possible that there's going
to be some training after may
on conduct on social media because there
seems to be a lot of complaints
on on that particular aspect
thank you chairman we do have annual
training and it does it is
focused around uh social media the
council has also got to policy on social
media so
there is annual training out there and
um
unfortunately i think because of the
past year we've had i
uh with no physical human contact i
think social media is the main
uh channel of communication at the
moment so
um but it is on the rise i do do agree
with
councilman
okay thank you thank you uh council mr
hoy have you got your hand back up or is
it a historic hand
i did put it back up again thank you
chairman if that's okay we'll come back
it's another
question which occurred to me on the
back of them counselor stanley's
questions um the report
in in our agenda the report says it's
for
um complaints raised between two certain
dates
are there and on this there are three
cases to be determined
are there any cases before this
which still have to be determined or are
those three the only ones still to be
determined
these are the three that are uh to be
determined there's no outstanding from
the last report
okay so there's only three thank you um
and
generally would outstanding ones from a
previous
report be included even though they if
they were still
outstanding they would be um
yes they would be included even though
they were complained for in the previous
yes whether it be by notifying members
an individual email just to know
um not promoting or whether it be within
the next report
right thank you thank you um councilman
oh yeah just to follow up chairman on um
councillor miss marriott's uh question
on training
district councillors receive training i
wonder if parish councillors receive
the same social media training or
should they because that's obviously an
area that needs to be looked at i
believe
chairman the training is offered to
parish councils and the clerks are made
aware of the training
thank you andrea i believe um that there
is also a training they can
take themselves through the local
government association
um right uh has anybody else got any
hands raised i
can't be any before i ask my question oh
linda thank you
thank you chairman um yeah i'm an
independent person
um i just wonder um given
you know the stresses and strains of
being in lockdown that we've all
suffered one way or another
um whether you've seen an increase in
the number of cases coming forward
um i know we've we've probably all seen
on the
on the news the um unfolding saga of
what's been going on in that parish
council in cheshire
and there was another one as well
somewhere i think i just wondered if
there'd been an increase
in um allegations because of
behavior um probably accentuated by
lockdown
um i don't think the complaints have
increased itself but the
uh con the type of complaints um as
councilman has said it
it's probably um social media based
rather than actual in physical meetings
if that makes sense but i'd in my
opinion i don't think the complaints
have
um increased by a a great amount
thank you have you any other question um
or follow-up questions
no that's fine that's uh that's just a
bit reassuring i think for all of us
thank you thank you um that that was
actually um
quite um
an important question at the moment
because a lot of um
how we're interacting with the public
has been pushed online
during this pandemic so um yeah no
wonder there's um
sort of been an increase regarding
social media
um i've got one question i think um
it's regarding item three again and it's
um really following up on councillor mr
hoy's um
question um that obviously
um you yourself angela um determined
the um outcome of this item
you said i'm based on the evidence that
you had seen
so my question is do you
go back to the complainant at all and
ask them if they have any additional
evidence or
have they got supplementary evidence at
all
um there are um ins there are cases
where i will go back to
the complainant to explain or clarify
their complaint
in this case there was evidence to for
to allow me to determine
um that the subject of complaint was not
acting in the capacity of
council however um complainants are
entitled to come back at any time
if they do have any new evidence or
further evidence or
if they have any new complaints um and
that's conveyed to them at the time is
it
it's not it's it's
i do you know sorry gem i can't remember
what i write in my
response letters um it is confirmed that
they're not happy that they can take the
matter further
thank you um it's just um uh as
um council mr hoy pointed out um
some of the technicalities around this
we're not
familiar with ourselves therefore some
of the members of the public or um
members outside of this arena might not
be as
clear with them as well yes chairman i
appreciate that and
obviously it's it's difficult to explain
technicalities when
um the evidence and and basis of
complaints is to be kept confidential at
these stages
um it's hard to explain how my
i make a judgment call without going too
deep into what kind of evidence i've
seen
thank you i think we've got one more
question um some
councillor uh mr lucas girl thank you
chair
um angela is there any uh course of
appeal
against your decision
no chairman there's no appeal against my
decision
is that right do you think
um you're asking for my opinion as to
whether
it's right it's it's what's in our
constitution it's what's in our
arrangements
there's no there's no um a
legal requirement to have an appeal
system in place they can go to the local
government ombudsman um to take the meta
further
okay thank you thank you um
any other questions um i can't see
anybody indicating
so um at the bottom of page
6.1 there is a recommendation
one recommendation that the summary of
the complaints and determinations for
the period
october 2020 to march 2021
be received is that noted members
please raise your hand icon if you're
not happy with that um
counselor mrs carter
yeah thank you chair um just um one of
the things i'd like to
um bring to your attention uh just a
consideration um
on 3.2 um it's um
in regards to the the the raised um
hand for the icon in a full council
meeting
is that okay to say something about that
um i don't think that's um appropriate
on this
meeting it's not on the agenda um
officers
no i'm just seeking guidance from
officers
it's not an agenda item counselor mrs
carter
i'm sorry i thought it was to do with
the um
where is it what does it say on there
it's all to do with the urgent decisions
to be made
is that not this meeting um
uh chairman there there is no item
around
urgent decisions for this evening's
meeting
that would be a matter for uh for
council there to uh to note
chairman i i believe there's a slightly
nice misunderstanding i believe the
urgent decisions is just in reference to
why this meeting is a remote meeting and
how we came about to having
to make meetings it's just for
information purposes chairman
thank you yes i thought so um
okay so um again i'll just run through
at the bottom of
page 6.1 there is one recommendation
that the summary
of complaints and determinations for the
period of october 2020 to march 2021 be
received
is that noted members i see no raised
hand
icon so i will take it that that is
noted
that then concludes the meeting uh thank
you everybody for attending
and i declare that the meeting is closed
at
7 52
by my clock have a good evening
everybody and keep safe
and hopefully where meet our post look
down
next time thank you thank you
thank you good night all